i am dallas came to a close over the
weekend and we actually got some pretty
cool story lines most importantly we got
to witness one of the greatest throwback
performances in the history of cs go
from the hungry man himself snacks the
28 year old was only supposed to be a
last-minute stand-in for ants but he
ended up stealing the show and was the
highest rated player for the team
overall
let's dive into how we got here
[Music]
okay i think it's fair to say that we
weren't expecting dallas to be this hype
not that it's a bad tournament or
anything it's just difficult to be the
one that follows up the major but
something in that dallas air must have
been different we got some incredible
highlights a huge shift in the power
rankings and videos of twist being a
real one signing autographs for four
plus hours and yes
yet another nico deagle whiff on new
nico from warehouse sports one not
looking the right way
something about nuke and uh deagles and
behind the headshots uh nico doesn't
really work all the time but like i said
at the start all of these things pale in
comparison to the individual performance
we got from ensa's stand-in snacks now i
know most of you already know who snacks
is by now but for those of you in our
audience who don't i think you need a
refresher yanu snacks pogrezelski is a
polish cs go player who is most famously
a part of that now legendary virtus plow
roster he's a major winner he's been on
the hltv top 20 four times and is
responsible for some of cs go's most
iconic plays to just snacks does find
one let's not leave him out of this the
big apple and snacks is hungry he's got
one kill already on the usp
low hp as well on guardian and flame
he's trying to bait them out trying to
get them into one on ones as he dances
back and forth between the box what a
shot on simple oh guardian bye bye and
it's on the blaming he's tapped it
flaming
what in god's name is that from snacks
unbelievable now since that roster
disbanded snax's time in the sun has
mostly come to an end he did still
remain competitive for a few years after
2019 by jumping between different polish
rosters but ever since the start of 2022
snax has mostly been playing with random
stacks and open qualifiers that was
until iem dallas rolled around you see
ants who have been playing great
recently would unfortunately find
themselves down a man when spinx ran
into visa troubles luckily for ants they
were able to secure snacks for the
tourney just a few days before it
started now it is very important to
point out that spanx is arguably one of
the most consistent players on ends so
snacks filling in for him was more of a
fun nostalgia trip for the community
than anything else what we weren't
expecting was a fallen's last dance
level return to form from the polish
powerhouse i mean this guy put on a
clinic so it's home to just snacks solo
as broke he is able to get the plant
down
carrick was not expecting snacks from
that angle at all and broke he has a
very winnable round ahead of him now
[Music]
works his way forward onto the site
but okay oh he just gets deleted snacks
that's vintage from snacks once again we
ask for more from snacks
sets himself on the line did twist spot
him out it doesn't matter a headshot and
king snacks will not be denied he's over
the top of him
good night stacks or send him to sleep
hell he was even the top rated player
against furia the most unpredictable
team of the tournament and faze the
literal best team in the world ants were
on fire and snack looked like he set
back the clock at least six years people
couldn't help but chime in on his
performance now i know what you guys are
thinking didn't we just release a video
about how jks was the greatest stand in
performance of all time well yes we did
and we stand by it after all jks helped
faze win iem katowice and despite snax's
best efforts and being the top performer
he couldn't make it happen for ends
everything about this event has been for
cloud9 ever since that victory over
phase we knew it would propel him to new
heights and cloud nine
they are your dallas champions but let's
just say if ends did defeat cloud9 well
then
well then our video would be wrong
now speaking of cloud9 we do need to
bring attention to their brilliant run
despite falling to the lower bracket c9
dominated their way back to the grand
finals and proved everybody that they
were still very much the real deal the
only thing that really put a damper on
c9's win was an oddly controversial
trophy lift you see jack the ceo of
cloud9 took to the stage to celebrate
with a cs go roster the moment they won
not exactly what you'd call weird but
jack doesn't have the greatest
reputation in the cs go community so it
did rub some people the wrong way now
what sent some people over the edge is
the fact that jack lifted the trophy
before anyone else on the team and they
even want jack to go for the trophy ief
champions clown nine in dallas
[Applause]
yes to be fair to jack the players did
insist for him to raise the trophy but
in my opinion if you're the ceo and
you're going on stage you're putting
them in a weird position jack is largely
responsible for the team having an org
to play under in the first place so i
don't really blame anyone if they happen
to infer some type of savior complex
going on on top of that there are some
people that think that jack only cares
about the cs go community when his team
wins so him swooping in can seem a
little tone deaf but don't let this
weird moment distract you from the fact
that c9 deserves your attention and
respect moving on from that drama
there's actually a few other storylines
worth mentioning most importantly that
vitality g2 and team liquid are
continuing to trend downwards yes phase
did slip up but they're coming off a
major win and na'vi i mean they weren't
even there so i think those two teams
are safe as for the rest of the big
hitters well it seems like some changes
are probably on the horizon if they want
to salvage the rest of the year that
being said there is one potential bright
side to this ongoing narrative with the
so-called established orcs struggling
and snacks giving us the performance
that he did who knows maybe we'll start
to see more last dance style squads pop
up closer to the rio major i don't want
to speak for you guys but i personally
would be very excited for cs go to enter
its renaissance era
but i shuffled it i'm putting all my all
my
all my spirit into these cards
and you received
what is this the nine no the ten of
swords
uh it's basically a guy stabbed ten
times so he stabbed in the back i'm sure
you'll be fine